just like think of like um your history
with the Beatles and like um all the
songs and the kids while we all grew up
listening to The Beatles music so like
it was you know we always just love
walking down here and seeing the street
name so when we finally found something
that was available we we jumped on it
this is Hearts Club yeah yeah it's
almost like um the neighborhoods kind of
took uh the harmony of the music on to
itself yeah I mean it's it's hard to say
a favorite but yeah I mean do I have a
favorite album probably The White Album
yeah you know but yeah I like all the
music from the early stuff to the to the
later stuff